oh
oh wow
nearly a week following will smith and
chris rock's now in from this oscar's
altercation new details are emerging
about how the comedian felt in the
moments after
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television a source tells e.t that after
the slap chris just wanted to leave the
grown-up star exited the stage and went
downstairs to production but no one from
the academy was there so that's when
chris went to oscar's producer will
packer's office where the police
questioned him it's a moment packer
discussed in detail on friday's good
morning america i made that clear like
rock you tell me whatever you want to do
brother and he was telling me
i'm fine
let's just get past this
i'm getting out of here i can't believe
this happened the lapd
came and needed to talk to chris they
were saying
this is battery we will go get him we
are prepared we're prepared to get him
right now you can press charges we can
arrest him
but our source says the actor still
didn't want to press charges against
will chris said he just wanted to leave
he got in his car immediately and left
wow dude
it was a g.i jane jump keep my wife's
name
i'm going to okay
as for removing the king richard star
from the ceremony well our source says
chris was never asked about it instead
it was up to packer and academy leaders
david rubin and dawn hudson it was not
chris's decision to make
they were about to physically remove
will smith i had not been a part of
those conversations i immediately went
to
the academy leadership that was on site
and i said
chris rock doesn't want that
rock has made it clear
that he does not want to make a bad
situation
worse that was chris's energy his tone
was not retaliatory his tone was not
aggressive and angry a source tells e.t
that the producer's interview with gma
was not set up by the academy nor does
will speak for the academy they are
taking matters into their own hands
telling e.t earlier this week we have
officially started a formal review
around the incident and will explore
further action and consequences
and until those matters are resolved
chris is getting back to work
the head of state star is back on stage
but during his comedy set he made it
very clear talk of the oscars was not
happening that night
about what happened
[Applause]
[Applause]
but it didn't stop people in the
audience from trying to get it out of
him a source tells et on night two of
chris's stop in boston two hecklers were
removed from the venue after yelling
will smith at first chris joked where
were y'all at the oscars but as the will
insults kept coming our source says the
actor defused the situation by saying no
no no
the source says chris is processing
everything that happened and will
respond in his own way on his own time
you